-♪♪ J-J-J-Jinx,
J-J-J-Jinx Challenge ♪♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We read a category from the
card, then we count to three
and both say something in
that category at the same time.
When we say the same thing,
it is a jinx.
Okay? And that's good.
We want jinx.
-Okay.
-We want jinx.
So first,
let's put on our gloves.
-Oh, look, it's labeled.
Will you only wear your glove
and not mine?
-Yeah, it's a contractual thing.
[ Light laughter ]
I think you have smaller hands.
-Wait. Oh, so I have to
use my left hand?
Is that how this works?
-I think so.
-Okay. Wow.
-Are you feeling this already?
-Wow.
-It kind of makes no sense.
I don't know why
we invented this.
But anyways,
when we get a jinx --
-Did you patent it?
-Yes. Well, we have to.
Get my lawyers right now.
Michael Cohen.
Oh, my God, he's in prison.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
So when we get a jinx, either
do that or we can do that.
I mean, whatever you want.
That's the whole fun
of the game.
-This is so exciting.
-This is the best thing
that ever happened.
Here we go.
All right. Ready?
I'm going to go first.
Ready?
-Okay.
-There's no rush.
This is all fun.
You can play at home --
-I'm stressed.
-No, don't. This is fun.
-How do you win?
-You win -- We all win.
[ Laughter ]
If you think about it.
-I'm too competitive.
-We all win. Everyone's
winners here, you know.
-Okay. Great.
-Yeah.
All right.
Green vegetable.
Actually, this is
green vegetables.
It's plural.
Green vegetable.
Grin vegetable.
Grn veg.
One, two, three.
Broccoli!
-Broccoli!
[ Ding ]
-Oh!
-Ohh!
-I'm feeling this.
All right, that's good.
One jinx!
-Okay, okay.
-You feeling it now?
-I'm feeling it.
-All right, here we go.
-Yeah, okay.
-Oh, sorry. You should read it.
-Oh, okay.
Animal sounds.
One, two, three.
Neigh!
-Woof!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-That was said
with such conviction.
-I was attacking because of
the horse in my backyard.
A very calm horse.
-Are we going for a second --
-Neigh.
Yes. Oh, yeah.
We only got one jinx.
But that's good. We got to beat
our record of one.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
In the time-honored tradition
of the Jinx Challenge,
this is a world record.
-Okay.
-Here we go. We can beat this.
Ready?
I'm talking about states.
-States.
Hmm.
States.
One, two, three.
New York!
-Kentucky.
I was going to say Kentucky.
But then I figured
we're in New York.
Yeah, I thought that was
kind of an easy one.
-Not thinking logically.
-No. Kentucky.
I was going to say Kentucky.
Is that weird?
-This is -- I'm, like,
getting into this look.
-Yeah.
But are you feeling the heat?
It feels like
the heat's being --
-Like knowledge
coming through my hands.
-Yeah.
And back this way, as well.
It's like...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, okay, good.
-Embarrassing.
-All right. Ready?
It was embarrassing.
Me?
-No.
-No. Of course not.
-Oh, wait. Okay.
Ooh.
French words.
-Uh-oh.
French words?
-French words.
Wait, don't you live in France
or something?
-I did for a minute.
-You did, okay.
So a French word.
-French word.
-Oh.
-Okay.
-Okay. A French word.
Okay.
I'm in France.
I'm just going to say a word.
A French word.
-French word.
One, two, three.
Bonjour.
-Oui!
-Oh.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-Gosh.
-Broccoli was --
We peaked on broccoli.
-It was real
when we were in broccoli.
-Let's focus up now.
Seriously, enough of the B.S.
-I know, man.
This is --
We're really --
-Let's go.
We want to beat this
and get to this, man.
These two are gonna be winners.
-I can't leave here a loser.
-Ready for this?!
-Ready.
Okay.
-Foods with holes.
One, two, three!
Bagel!
-Bagel!
-Yeah!
[ Ding ]
We felt it. We felt it.
-That felt so right.
-Oh, it felt so right.
Foods with holes.
Bagels, of course.
-Yes.
-Yes!
Let's go to the last chance.
Here we go, Natalie Portman.
-Okay. Pop stars.
Okay.
-I got it.
One, two, three.
-Two, three.
Lady Gaga!
-Sia!
-Oh, of course, Sia.
[ Buzzer ]
Darn it!
Two is better than one.
One for each of us.
Natalie Portman, everybody.